i always want to be great at anything i
do nicki minaj gets
super personal about motherhood i do
feel like a queen
the rapper gave birth to her first child
a baby boy with hubby kenneth petty back
in september
and on thursday the 38 year old proud
mama sent out a letter to her fans on
the mailing list
and opened up about being his mom saying
she's been quote
completely overwhelmed with joy each day
creates a new
and fascinating magical memory that i
hide far away into a little cute
compartment of my heart
vowing never to forget any of it how
cute is that
well thank you but she didn't stop there
she likened her little one to a cute
little marshmallow
and revealed his favorite flick is
madagascar escape to africa
excuse me excuse me i'm marty
i'm kind of new around here
he's so smart funny sweet competitive
it's kind of crazy how they have a full
personality so early on
yesterday i made him say mama even got
it on video
and my heart just melted hopefully one
day she'll share
that video with the barbs i'm very
excited about that
but until then she's just over here
blessing us with music
i did a couple new joints for the
mixtape
this is just to get back to the basics a
little bit
um to the essence of why i started
rapping
on thursday after taking a hiatus and
returning to social media
nikki dropped some big news on insta
live
revealing that her beam me up scotty
mixtape would be available on streaming
platforms for the first time
ever she also got honest with her fans
saying she was on hiatus because she was
in mommy mode
and had a little writer's block but
after feeling stuck
she said she called up drake and asked
him who had the hottest sound out there
and he sent her the song seeing green
drake
love you too duff drake well drake was
watching her live so she connected with
him and they talked about the single
it didn't feel right with you not being
on it that's really the best way i could
put it it was like
it was fun the other way but it's it's
epic this way you know
and drake addressed nikki's hiatus to be
with her son
you know i had some real heart to heart
to you lately like just about
the fact that it's like it's just your
world nobody does it
better than you and it's like when
you're gone you know obviously
papa bear is here now so we are you know
we understand the priorities
but you know when you're gone i'm not
gonna lie like i'm sure i speak for
everybody in the live when it's like yo
we really miss you like
we really miss your presence and just
like we miss the bars
we miss the excitement that you bring so
it's like
you know i just like i've been on you
lately to just you know you know what
time it is
you